- I know a lot of people.
I know a lot of people in real life,
a lot of people who are really nice,
who do great things for me.
Somehow though this man has found a way
to do more for me than anyone else
before I ever had the chance to
shake his hand or give him a hug.
(soft piano music)
- What's up Linkedin.
I'm sitting here with a
friend but she doesn't
have make-up on so she
doesn't want to be on video,
which is ludicrous.
I'm still going to put the
camera on you so you better
duck your head if you don't want it.
I love it, I love it, I love it.
Anyway we're having a very
nice time we're just meeting.
And I have a lot of passion
for what I'm about to say.
A lot of people are
overthinking content creation.
She's an incredible
three time entrepreneur.
She has unbelievable amounts
of knowledge in her head
and I'm like you just
need to write on Linkedin
or video like I'm doing now.
So what I'm doing right
now is actually very meta.
I'm just recording this and
now I'm going to post it.
And I'm just going to
write a caption or two
and I'm gonna post it to just show her
literally there's just no friction
in content creation anymore.
You don't need to hire that much staff.
A lot of people get confused now
because I have a big team
producing my content,
but like I'm a full-fledged
media company now.
For eight years I did it all by myself.
That's how I got to the point of being
able to afford people to do it.
So produce content.
You've got a thought, write.
You see something in the world
and you've got two cents to add,
deploy those two pennies.
Please produce content.
It is the gateway drug
to everything you want.
Your guy's strategy clearly
to me is that watch page
is going to get me more
consumption long term,
and so we're going to siphon off the page
to get people on to watch.
Correct?
Because that's kind of what you're doing
with the post pushing there.
- No I don't want to siphon off anything.
I think honestly I want your
Facebook hits to be better.
Your personal one.
Using that YouTube I just
took your Twitter copy
and drove to that YouTube link
of the kid and it did well.
Got 5,000 link clicks
just saying the feedback
on this video has changed.
(sneezing)
Making it more personal to
you doing more personal stuff.
- It's actually very
smart what you just said.
You know torchna, the Russian
thing I was talking about?
If you sneeze what you're saying is true.
Or what you're thinking.
So I was just about to say ,
oh right, that makes sense.
We should be using--
Since I'm first person
on Twitter and Instagram,
we should, Facebook should
be taking and behind
those two taking it, it will crush.
I'm going to use it to encourage
people to push positivity.
Instead of making it about me
and just a flattering piece for me,
I'm gonna frame it as you
never know when a positive
piece of content, you just
never fucking know when a
positive piece of content
fucking changes somebody's life.
Everybody's being so selfish and worrying
about how many likes they're
getting, or followers.
You can make a piece of content
that changes somebody's life.
It's fucking true.
- So since Tuesday.
- Like, people don't get it.
You know how you heard that one album
and like that one song,
and it made you become an artist?
Or you saw that one
Michael Jordan, fuck him.
You saw that one Dominique Wilkins game
and you became a basketball player?
Like, some kid's watching
Ninja right now play Fortnite,
and is literally going
to be one of the great
professional e-sports players,
and then one video I make
about going to Craigslist,
this Craigslist free--
actually, I want that video.
Craigslist free, Facebook marketplace,
like it's working.
But that, what happened
the other day, just...
I will not feel that
good when I buy the Jets,
I promise you.
I will not.
One piece of content
can change somebody's life.
- A thousand.
- We need a thousand emoji.
We need a, they need to add a...
- We'll add it to the...
- So what happened?
- A thousand.
- Oh, a thousand was the answer.
I thought you were saying a thousand,
like I say a hundred.
We just invented the
thousand emoji by accident.
All right, everybody out, I'm not kidding.
A thousand? Is that good?
- It's solid.
I mean, if you think--
- What are you telling me, it's solid?
It had to be a very big day by comparison.
I was getting blown up.
- Yeah
- What's my nor--
- Out of, it's like 200.
- You would have liked to see more,
is what you're saying.
- Yeah. I would have liked 2,000.
- Sorry.
- [Man Off Camera] How
enthusiastic you were,
I was guessing five.
- Got it.
That's too bad.
All right, you guys ruined my day.
- [Man Off Camera] You
saw we changed (mumbling)
- Hey Alexa, can I buy Gary Vee's new
003 K-Swiss Collab sneakers?
- [Alexa] One moment.
I couldn't find anything
for 03 Case Collab sneakers.
What else would you like?
- Gary Vee K-Swiss.
Hey Alexa, can you buy
the Gary Vee K-Swiss?
Sorry, Alexa.
Hey, Alexa?
I want Gary Vee's K-Swiss.
- [Alexa] Sorry, I'm not sure.
(piano music)
- If I work for this company,
if I even knew, if you
even just called my bluff
if I'm telling the truth,
the ROI of having a relationship with me,
you're gonna get a much
better job and make more money
literally because we have a relationship.
- So balancing relationships.
And I use the word balance
because I prefer harmony.
How does one get the ability to
prioritize both a marriage
and a big business like VaynerMedia?
- [Other Man] I want to know that too.
- Two things.
And you know, wanting to know that now,
there's one vulnerability to that.
- For sure.
- The way to actually do it,
in one man's point of view,
is have a significantly candor-oriented
conversation up front.
I basically told my
wife in the first date,
and the whole second date was,
I'm gonna work every minute.
And like, getting to know her, and like,
"Oh, your dad worked every minute."
Great. That's an
environment you come from.
Now some people may go the other--
Disproportionate
over-communication up front
which not everybody does,
and then disproportionate
over-communication when you're in it.
And by the way, if things happen--
what's that?
- And so many of that,
are you sure you want to?
- Yeah, so that's great.
And then, like bro,
everything is communication.
Very simply, this is how life works.
Poison, poison lives in the shadows,
and happiness lives outside.
Period. All of it.
Got it?
- Got it.
- And so like the shade I throw,
I don't begrudge anyone.
Everybody should do
everything they want to do.
Who the fuck am I?
I mean this.
But I only throw shade when I think
people aren't being very
authentically clear.
And don't tell me you're a good person
and joining a non-profit
board because you love it.
Tell me that you're
joining a non-profit board
because you're trying
to get to that person
and you know they're on the board.
And it's nice that the collateral.
VaynerMedia.
I always say VaynerMedia's the best
because I want to buy brands.
That's why my clients
are getting the benefit.
Not because I'm fucking
the best dude ever.
- It's not ego, it's..
- Got it?
Do you understand?
Be authentic with the
fucking you're up to.
Don't be like "I'm trying
to change the world.
"Sign up for my $80,000 mastermind."
You know what I mean?
And I don't begrudge anybody.
I want people to be transparent
because kids are getting tricked.
And then depression kicks in.
It's not about me, I'm gonna get mine.
Alex, do you have crushing it sneakers?
How'd you get 'em?
You know what you're gonna
sell those for one day?
- I know.
This is the first day I wore 'em.
It's been on my desk for months.
- Amazing.
Nice shoes, guys. Thanks a lot.
This is fucking amazing.
It's so fucking nice out.
Oh God, I love it.
New York fucking City.
It's so nice out.
- 6:00 a.m., baby, left
at 3:00 a.m. from Albany.
From 6:00 a.m. I was here.
Damn right, tweet at Gary at 6:00 a.m.
3:00 a.m., actually woke up at a 2:30,
left around 2:45, we're here now.
- I come from Australia, so.
On holiday here with my kids,
so I left them in
Central Park to see Gary.
They're not happy with me.
- And just get his advice on where to go
from where I'm at now.
I'm at a pretty good space,
and I'm just on that uptick.
That exponential growth curve.
But I'm ready to start, so, you know.
Asking for advice on, you know,
what to do from here.
I kind of know the answer,
but it's always good to hear from him.
- I congratulated him when he
hit a million followers on Facebook.
And I was there, and he commented.
Like, he's a real guy.
He's motivated me to
start blogging on medium.
So I've been taking a lot
of advice from Gary Vee.
- When that video went
viral of him talking
to the college grads,
and I kind of just like jumped on ship
and been watching his content ever since.
It's always like a good motivator
every time I see him.
- Probably it's the one
about put your head down
until you're 29,
kind of get me focused not to,
not to just think about
too much right now,
just to work, get a good work ethic,
and see what happens from there.
- Take what you have and do what you can.
And don't cry, don't think negative,
just take positivity and remember
that positivity will always win.
That's the best thing
in life you can have.
- I want to be an
entrepreneur when I grow up.
I'm very into it.
- Yo, everyday, live your dreams.
Not following your dreams,
you're not chasing your dreams.
You're living in the present moment,
you're living the dream.
Enjoy the process, enjoy the climb.
Enjoy the journey.
- Everything he says is pretty inspiring.
- When you're eating dirt like Gary says,
or when you're in the
clouds and enjoying it,
you gotta make the best of both.
- I have a list of
people who I look up to,
and he's actually right there.
A signature would be nice,
but right there.
And at this point, this guy's becoming
a historical figure and I
don't even think he knows it.
He's gonna be like on of those people
in the history books.
He's gonna be amazing.
A lot of people don't know that.
There's people walking
by and they ask people,
"Who is Gary Vee?"
And I'm just sitting here like "Wow."
I'm ready. I'm excited.
I'm really excited.
- [Gary] What's the one piece
of content that's like...
(slapping)
- [Man] Every day I was in a dark place.
- You were just looking at
it from the wrong angle.
It's just fucking angles.
Just wrong angles.
- Brought the life that's
inside of me back out.
He made me believe that I could
work and do things to put
myself in a different position
rather than be stuck at where I was
and complain and sit in
things like victimhood
and negativity and blaming others.
The stuff that gets you nowhere.
And he literally peeled back the curtain
and was like, "Dude, the grass is greener.
"All you gotta do is
hop the fucking fence."
That's how I felt about it.
That's what I started doing.
And it's only been a micro-step
in the grand scheme of things,
and how it's going to play out.
I have no idea what's
next, so coming out here,
remind myself why I'm
doing what I'm doing,
and to literally just thank him.
Pay my respects for everything
that he's done for me.
And Gary if you're watching this,
thank you again so much.
- I want to say that I'm in a new zone.
I am. I'm seeing clearer than ever.
I'm getting better and
better by the second.
It's coming man.
Next level of my content's here.
I'm starting to understand.
And my target's the fucking Joneses.
My target's the fucking Joneses.
- [Man Off Camera] I feel
like experience is something
that we don't really talk about.
- Yeah, you're right, like
I'm evolving too, right?
Like, I'm meta, right?
Like I'm living, having
more conversations,
and shit's becoming more obvious to me
as I go through it.
And like, yeah man, absolutely.
My answers are getting stronger.
'Cause I put in the work.
I read all the comments.
I understand.
I see what hits a mark, what doesn't.
And now that I'm three
or four years into it,
the people that are coming to me,
and their lives have changed,
I can see the pattern recognized, right?
I can see the pattern recognize.
Like that's the key.
- [Man Off Camera] The
man's a machine right now.
- I'm feeling good about myself.
I'm feeling real good about myself.
- If Nike is to world class athletes
and Adidas is to like,
we'll say, pop culture,
what or who is the association, you know,
linking up with you, the K-Swiss?
K-Swiss is--
- Entrepreneurs.
Fucking entrepreneurs.
Like, I remember when Jordans came out
because I hated him with all my heart.
Kids put those Jordans on,
and I never put Jordans on.
No Jordans, mom, in the house. Zero.
Because I literally remember this.
I'm giving a shout out to Greg DiTomaso.
Greg, I hope somebody who knows you
pulls this up and forwards you this video.
I remember Greg DiTomaso
freshman year of high school
putting on Jordans, and I swear to God,
he literally changed his entire behavior.
He literally thought
he was Michael Jordan.
And I'm gonna say this,
this is a big shout out to Greg DiTomaso.
Greg DiTomaso got better at
basketball systematically
because his demeanor changed,
his mindset changed, and he put in work.
He didn't go to the pros
or anything like that.
But people laughed at him freshman year,
and he fucking started senior year,
and there was no reason he should've.
Not only he started,
he was probably best player on the team.
Our team sucked shit, but
that's a whole different story.
If one, one.
If one person puts these on,
thinks about what I'm trying
to drill into their dome,
and gets a little bit better
at what they're trying to achieve,
then I've won because admiration
is the currency for me,
I've come to realize in my older age.
And the way you get true admiration
is making impact and I like making...
You know, and I love business.
I love selling sneakers.
I love hustling.
I told Tyler, I was like yo,
while all these people are in line,
tell them to buy an extra pair.
Like I'm a salesman.
I'm not Mother Theresa.
But the collateral of my ambition
being good is psh.
Crew goals!
- Come on Justin,
Get in here, Justin!
- Let's go, Justin!
Come on baby.
Bel Biv Devoe, what?
- G-Dog, come on.
- We're drinking vodka out of a sneaker
with my crazy uncle Misha.
- In Russia when you have a new car,
or new item or new something to wear,
you always need to drink to this
or always in the new for the good health.
So we drinking vodka out of a new sneaker
for the good health,
and for the good health of you.
- That's how he does it.
I love you.
- I love you!
And remember children.
- Drink vodka out of sneakers.
- And always use your brain.
And remember the crazy Russian uncle
always love you!
- Loves you!
- I love you.
- ♪ You got me stuck on positivity ♪
♪ Oh my God, Gary Vee, ♪
♪ You always get 'em to like and retweet ♪
♪ Is it because of your empathy ♪
♪ Because I know that you care about me ♪
♪ You remind me not to be lazy ♪
♪ Get me off my ass every day, every day ♪
♪ Has something to say to make an impact ♪
♪ Working so hard he'll be
the first and the last ♪
♪ If you want to crush it, listen up, ♪
♪ 'Cause he's got the recipe ♪
♪ He reminds us, his
self-awareness is the key ♪
- You been well?
- Yeah, man, doing well.
- It's good to see you.
My business partner Jose.
- Jose. How are you my guy?
It's a real pleasure.
- We met at wine library.
Remember what you told me
about letting things go?
- And?
- Best advice ever.
You know, I didn't go there
to hear that thing that day.
But it's what came, and--
- It's what you needed.
- The things that we been working on
is unbelievable since I--
- My guy.
Once people figure out
that this is the game,
everything changes.
- We put something together
that not many people could put together.
The network that we put together--
- Bone thugs, baby, bone fucking thugs!
- is crazy.
- I'm so proud of you.
- ♪ Man I don't give a damn
what another man think ♪
♪ I'm done chasing pink ♪
♪ I'd rather wear mink in the summer ♪
♪ Like that damn boy heating up ♪
♪ Swear that I'm a bad niggy
'fore the season's up ♪
♪ I'm re'in up ♪
♪ Making sure the stock is right ♪
♪ Nowadays got me thinking
like it's Harlem Nights ♪
♪ With black on black
and plaques on plaques ♪
♪ And stacks on stacks and germo-racks ♪
♪ Had to hand it to him
it was just a dream ♪
♪ Till I worked for it ♪
♪ Stopped believing in people
that didn't work for it ♪
♪ And it all came like the
kid really meant for it ♪
♪ God's gift only paying
if I sent for it ♪
♪ Saw they left a tight
spot but I went for it ♪
♪ Now the block's hot every
nigga rockin' Ventwood ♪
♪ They love me when the
struggle start stoppin' ♪
♪ Drive to the bank and
a nigga start clockin' ♪
♪ Yeah, and a nigga start clockin' ♪
♪ Bang bang ♪
♪ Yeah a nigga start ♪
♪ What you thought this shit was handed ♪
♪ I couldn't have planned it any better ♪
♪ Worked seven summers
for that foreign leather ♪
♪ And the Jag with a tag
saying go and get it ♪
♪ I been the king since the
hair couldn't fit the fitted ♪
♪ I'm the alpha and omega translation ♪
♪ I'm the greatest revelation ♪
♪ Making statements ♪
♪ Fuck your patience ♪
♪ Y'all been hating ♪
♪ I been waitin', stacking paper, ♪
♪ Throwing this vacant time for tasting ♪
♪ Feeling like pockin' a four ♪
♪ But that ain't never happened before ♪
♪ so I'm the revolutionary ♪
♪ Before the canaries with
the vet takin' checks ♪
♪ from too many bitches ♪
♪ Like a Mack when I was back and forth ♪
♪ Push the Jag no tags
down Providence Road ♪
♪ Tryna' make enough money
for my mama's bills ♪
♪ So if I really want
it I go get it at will ♪
♪ To my niggas that's real ♪
♪ Young and chasing a mil ♪
- Come here.
This guy right here, this guy right here,
works at VaynerMedia.
What's he doing right now?
Side hustling, working the party.
He's the only person I grabbed tonight
and said, "You inspire me so much.
"I look up to you so much."
- Put in hours. Gotta put in hours.
- I fucking, I admire it.
Imagine having the humility
to being okay to work
as a service provider for a party
where your co-workers are,
that see you everyday, as
a senior e-com executive,
but you have the strength
to be the fucking server
at a party with your friends are at,
and your business friends.
That's fucking mindset.
That I fucking admire.
- I appreciate that.
I'm fucking proud of you, bro.
Only person I said
anything to at this party.
- Thank you, I appreciate it.
That's what it's all about.
- It is.
You got a minute to--
you're gonna get fired, bro, go.
You're about to get fired.
That dude is an e-com
executive at VaynerMedia,
making real money,
and he has the humility
to work a side hustle job
as a caterer for an event where
10 to 15 of his co-workers.
I have so much respect for him.
You can't even imagine.
- That's the game, dude.
- I'm gonna come right back.
♪ Tired of niggas saying I changed ♪
♪ Tired of niggas saying I
ain't ready for the fame ♪
♪ I don't even sound like Cole ♪
♪ He don't even sound like Hov' ♪
♪ Shots all around for my woes ♪
♪ If you want to run it it's a go ♪
♪ Gleese in the trunk was
a legend in the four ♪
♪ Heard they live forever
like the pot on the stove ♪
♪ I been cooking out
since back when I was ♪
♪ Down on J Grove ♪
♪ And I'm the real reason
that you're not here ♪
♪ I'm the real reason
that you switched gears ♪
♪ I'm the real reason that you ain't ♪
♪ drop your album in the summer ♪
♪ 'cause you know the young nigga here ♪
♪ And I'm the real reason
that you're not here ♪
♪ I'm the real reason
that you switched gears ♪
♪ I'm the real reason that you ain't ♪
♪ drop your album in the summer ♪
♪ 'cause you know the young nigga here ♪
♪ So I told 'em whoa ♪
- Great job. Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
See you tomorrow.
- We should incorporate more lavender.
- Agree. Lavender is a
stunningly good color for me.
- I mean, most colors are stunningly good,
but I think the compliments--
- Guys, me and lavender is underrated.
- Yeah, 100 percent.
- Agree.
This is...
- A hundred percent.
- Trying to see what
D-Rock is trying to do.
I know you. I know you now.
See you tomorrow.
♪ I'm the real reason that
you ain't drop your album ♪
♪ In the summer 'cause you
know the young nigga here ♪
♪ So I told 'em whoa ♪